maybe even more so in children although
it is difficult to parse the data that
we are being shown because we are not
generally being shown all of it as
always the data are duped all the way
down some level um even more so for
children to the extent that children
suffer from covid and the vast vast vast
majority of them do not to the extent
that they do
they almost always have a comorbidity
and obesity is
is one of the major ones for children as
well children don't die of coping and
they don't get sick from copen here is
um
the cdc's
data uh i i'm trying here to go to
the government
the government's information the cdc the
fda exactly the people he would expect
if they are not giving us everything
they are going to air in the direction
that serves their narratives yes as
opposed to even by their own numbers
even by their own numbers
what we have here is um
is deaths this is through uh
12 15 20 21 so it's updated regularly
starting with january 1st 2020 each line
is
um
[Music]
it's split by sex uh an age
total deaths in that age group for this
period of time and deaths attributed to
covid i will say you know they say covet
19 deaths i'm going to say deaths
attributed to covet because increasingly
that's one of the ways that we are sure
that the data are being juked for
instance and this is one of the places
that the literal bodies are figuratively
buried is by
categorizing things
and it's clear you and i've been through
this multiple times it is clear that
there is a narrative that starts this
right covet is to be maximally
terrifying and the one-size-fits-all
vaccine policy is to be maximally
beneficial and things are moved by
category in order to reflect that
narrative even though it's clearly not a
straightforward conclusion exactly
so for those just listening i'm gonna
i'm gonna scroll down i'm gonna try to
no doesn't want me to um
and uh
and show
that as you get to you know
as you go up in age again this is just
this is just girls coming into women the
number of deaths in the age group
increase because deaths increase um you
know you have a lot of deaths in the
first year of life because uh we are we
are born fragile and we become
anti-fragile uh with age if we are
allowed to be um but we are born very
fragile and fragile and easy to misplace
we never did that i swear to god
um that's what screaming's about yes
that is what screaming that's how it
starts out yeah um so the you know the
overall deaths in the group
unfortunately you can't oh actually um
here sorry uh i can't nope don't show
that zack sorry here we go um
yeah you can show this this is just the
same data in a spreadsheet
where you can see that
i didn't i didn't make the formatting
nice uh the number of deaths increases
as you go up and the number of coba
deaths increases
up until um
you know the number of deaths in women
over 85 was is well over a million uh
total deaths and the number of cove
deaths attributed to covid are over a
hundred thousand
that's consistent with the kinds of
numbers we've seen and now we start over
this is this is now males and again it
starts out super low and it just climbs
and climbs and climbs and if we look at
just
the 18 and under mortality data
we have a total number of deaths
attributed to cobit in
people under 18 in the u.s is 655
across the entire pandemic 655 deaths
in the u.s for people under 18 and if
you take out that first year uh where
you're super fragile and even more so
who knows to what extent those um dead
with covet was actually dead of covid if
you take those out you're less than 500
you're at 492 total cove deaths
according to the cdc's numbers
uh in the u.s across the entire pandemic
so what does that tell us um that tells
us again um that children aren't dying
of coven
and
that furthermore
we've got to be careful i mean obviously
500 is
a lot of kids it's a tiny number it's a
tiny number compared to all of the kids
who have died and
uh and the fact is that compared to
every older age group
is a tiny number
um so yes it's not binary it's not zero
yep but it's actually closer than any
other
demographic description of a disease
progression that i as i've seen well i
would also leave open the possibility
that it is zero given the noise but i
just want to say 500 if that's the real
number right it's not zero it's a large
number of kids in absolute terms but
compared to other causes of death it is
very tiny and i think i know where
you're headed here
you were not headed somewhere further
i'm i'm going somewhere further but i
didn't think you were done with your
sentence sorry
it was one of those sentences that just
ended abruptly in the middle it was a
sentence cliff and i see okay um
well
man nothing is working quite so one of
the places i wanted to go from here is
to show this fda document that came out
in october
uh
october 26 2021
called vaccines and related biological
products advisory committee meeting this
was a document prepared again by the fda
in service of allowing mrna coded
vaccines in 5 to 11 year olds so again
the point of this document is to provide
evidence that what we need are euas four
five to eleven for the vaccines to be
allowed in five to eleven year olds
which of course as we know were granted
so again just like with the cdc data um
i'm going to the source that i would
expect to have um
to be to be biased towards the narrative
not away from the narrative and yet and
yet even here
we find things that don't quite fit uh
with the narrative here's here's their
page four and i will this is a pdf that
i'm showing but i'll link
i'll post the link in the show notes
this is coveted weekly cases
in
across all age groups
and it looks it looks scary you know
look at those peaks the peaks for all
age groups you have the light blue line
um is lowest that's zero to four year
olds and it basically gets the peaks get
higher the older the age groups are um
but the peaks are mirroring one another
to some degree okay um that seems like
um evidence that you might want to be
thinking about but then you go to page
11 in this document
and what this is doing for those just
listening is tracking
flu deaths or no flu hospitalizations
and covet hospitalizations uh flew from
2017 um yearly from the 2017-2018 year
flu season 2018 2019 2019 20 20 20 21
and then covered from the beginning or
actually from october 2020 uh through
september 2021 so a comparable amount of
time they've
controlled for the amount of time
ish
and what we find here is that you know
yes mitigation
measures have been in place and so you
would expect hopefully covid was
spreading less than it might have been
and the flu was spreading less that
might have been
but check out that flu cases are
effectively zero there are nine
pediatric influenza hospitalizations
reported between in the 2020 to 2021
uh flu season nine
compared to um in other years
um
you know we don't actually have the
absolute numbers we just have rates per
hundred thousand of the population the
rates are so low from last year that
it's effectively zero as you can see on
this on this and they of course have not
given us the actual ability to compare
apples to apples here
and
the covid
hospitalizations are lower
than pediatric hospitalizations from flu
in previous years again there were
mitigation measures in in place um and
but you know but
still
what happened was flu dropped to nothing
so none of none of those
hospitalizations happened and we know
that at least in some cases
some of the tests that were supposedly
testing for covid were impossible to
discriminate between whether or not they
were testing for covert or flu
so how many of these covet cases who are
actually flu cases we don't we don't
necessarily know we don't know i mean
and i will say the
flu number dropping to zero could be
a lot of different things it could have
a lot of different contributors and we
need to point out that one possibility
is
data shenanigans that uh basically if it
coughs it has covid kind of a thing
more likely i would say is the strong
possibility that flu has become very
well adapted to our modern way of life
and we thoroughly disrupted our modern
way of life and interrupted its ability
to transmit so flu had a rotten year
because we just simply weren't behaving
normally poor flu yeah poor flu but um
but anyway the the overarching point is
from the perspective of
addressing
the hazard to children that hazard has
to be scaled relative to flu in an
average year and the question is
are these vaccines
something that one should
offer to children should mandate for
children encourage for children in light
of the scale of the hazard
and
um
the problem is that
you know they've gotten in the way of
every piece of the analysis that
rational independent people without a
dog in the fight would have to go
through in order to figure out what the
comparison is but at the very least even
if we knew nothing
of actual harm coming to children from
these vaccines which is not the state
we're in but even if that was the state
you would have to rate the risk that
there was something that would happen to
these children if vaccinated later in
life as too large to contemplate in
light of the very small risk that comes
from covet itself even given the way
that numbers are calculated to inflate
that hazard
i
absolutely agree
and
two more slides from this uh document
that the fda produced
here we have children aged 5 to 11 years
hospitalized with covert 19
this is march 2020 through august 2021
and what we don't see here
is
this is outcomes in children versus
comorbidities that's underlying medical
conditions
but what we don't see is a number of
you know how many kids who ended up
hospitalized with covid
had any comorbidities that's the number
i want to see and i don't see it here
but what we do see is how many kids who
are hospitalized had greater than one oh
no that's equal to or greater than one
underlying conditions
um that's 68 percent
so
more than two-thirds
of the kids who were hospitalized with
covet have
one or more underlying conditions and
their underlying conditions frankly uh
include chronic lung disease obesity
cardiovascular disease
and you know things like feeding tube
dependence
and chronic metabolic disease but these
don't include all of the co-orbitals
that we know exist for kovid
and also of course none of this includes
one of the factors that we have now come
to understand from our own research and
from conversations we've had
that vitamin d deficiency is likely to
be you know if you add that in here i'll
bet that number 68 percent of kids
hospitalized with covid have at least
one underlying condition if you count
vitamin d deficiencies underlying
condition i'll bet that number goes
pretty close to one right and
if you were i mean we don't know it's
possible that the extremely compelling
vitamin d data does not include kids
because in all likelihood that work was
done on adults and so that and kids are
better able to synthesize vitamin d
right um so we have to leave open the
formal possibility that that the the
pattern the small amount of covetin
or the small amount of coverage covet
disease that is worth talking about is
not heavily impacted by d and kids
there's no reason to think that the
assumption should be in the other
direction that kids more or less mirror
the adult pattern but we have to leave
open the possibility
but nonetheless
from the point of view of would you
rather gamble on giving a young person
with many more decades of life in front
of them and much more development to go
through a brand new technology vaccine
that oh by the way doesn't prevent
contracting the disease and doesn't
prevent transmitting the disease and
doesn't seem to reduce viral load but is
really great other than that right which
it and you may well become dependent on
more on more of it right so the number
of boosters in a lifetime you might have
to get is likely to be higher would you
rather go that route with all of the
uncertainties involved in all of that
or would you rather try vitamin d and
see whether the very minor problem that
kids seem to have with kovid can be
largely addressed because they have a
cryptic vitamin d deficiency like
everybody else yes like everybody else
living in the temperate zones and i mean
of course we should say as we you know
this is a point that we were hammering
early on in in our dark horse live
streams
uh that we don't know the long-term
effects of coven
uh we don't know the degree to which
children who have long-hull covet uh
will in fact you know may have shortened
life may have you know worse outcomes
from long covet because it has the
potential to last for longer because
they have longer life span ahead of them
etc we haven't we have no information on
this just as we don't on on anyone
because this thing has been around for a
long time at this point but it's still
in only two years right
but but that said all of the information
that we do have suggests that you know
yes obesity is a risk factor across all
age groups and children are at lowest
risk for bad outcomes from the disease
and they are um at
the same or in fact higher risk for bad
outcomes adverse events from the
vaccines especially boys as we've
outlined in other places on on the show
and so you know what
why is it
um that we are being asked to
enable a one-size-fits-all policy it's
not because
we're too dumb to track it
that may be part of the story and you
hear that from people people are too
stupid to keep track and so you just
need to give them one solution and
that's what they'll do
uh you know we all get into that
headspace sometimes my god i don't want
to make another decision i just want to
have brand loyalty decision loyalty
something i want to just vote blue i
want to buy that kind of toothpaste i
want to go to that restaurant in order
that thing i just want to not think
about you know i've got i've got choice
fatigue
that is gaming
the fatigue that we all experience
rather than actually
a organic situation people do not want
to be handed single answers that don't
actually fit all solutions and are being
told that they fit all solutions
especially at the point that
they come to realize they've been lied
to and that those lies have effects they
have effects on individual health and
societal health on economic health on
all the healths
yeah
it's
it doesn't make any sense that this is
about we can't handle the complexity for
one thing um
much of the vaccine hesitancy surrounds
a lot of us having seen the complexity
and
saying actually there's
uh
too much uncertainty here to contemplate
this and though you know the longer that
we wait and the more we learn the more
frightening the picture that emerges
from what is apparently already known
becomes so i would point out in in
thinking about this question you're
comparing it against a lot of unknowns
with respect to how much hazard there is
to kids in these brand new novel
vaccines that would be true if there had
been no observation of harm whatsoever
but we are not in that circumstance in
fact
even in pfizer's trial on kids
which was tiny it was like 1200 kids
there was an absolutely serious adverse
event with permanent effects the maddie
degary case i think that's how you
pronounce your name
maybe diggory but
in any case this was a girl really a
hero of the pandemic somebody who
volunteered to
test the vaccines because she wanted to
contribute to the solution to covid
she now has a feeding tube is
permanently in a wheelchair
and the reaction of pfizer was to
unblind very quickly and
basically she was
she was
written down in the report as if she had
had stomach upset this is a person who
is now on a feeding tube right this is a
person who is permanently injured in a
you know a group of about 1200 kids
that's not an insignificant number you
know in 1200 kids even a very high rate
of very serious reactions could have
been missed but in this case there
actually is a person she has a name and
she has a life ahead of her and you know
pfizer is effectively pretending that
she doesn't exist or is faking or
something like that and it's
preposterous and the fact is parents
have a right to know this and they have
a right to say no to these things
[Music]